hello everyone today we're going to be
reviewing items from McDonald's Italy we
entered through them at Cafe entrance
and right by the counter was this
glorious display of goodies and oh my
God you cannot tell me you wouldn't buy
it all off the bat presentation looked
and smelled delicious they had these
menu items called Temptations and we got
these pizza pockets and wings the wings
were my favorite by far they were so
crispy and so juicy the streets in Rome
were plastered with advertisements for
the Bacon series so we got the mcbacon
and the bacon fries and both were all
right there was nothing really special
about them lastly I tried this avocado
chicken bacon burger and it was actually
pretty good I took my leftovers to go
and ended the trip with the pistachio
McFlurry and oh my it was Heavenly I'm
definitely coming back for this